el anuncio del presidente de el salvador
nadie bukele de buscar la reelección en
las presidenciales del 2024 no deja de
ser polémico ya que a pesar que existe
expresamente un pleno constitucional a
la reelección una vez concluido su
periodo de cinco años una resolución en
septiembre del 2021 de la sala de lo
constitucional de la corte suprema de
justicia afín al oficialismo abrió esa
posibilidad al mandatario salvadoreño en
esa ocasión la sala señaló que la
prohibición de la reelección inmediata
es para un gobernante que haya estado en
el poder por 10 años mientras que en
sentencias anteriores un mandatario
debía terminar su periodo de cinco años
y esperar diez para buscar nuevamente la
presidencia tras el sorpresivo aviso las
reacciones no se han hecho esperar
algunos constitucionalistas han
advertido que tal decisión iría en
contra del ordenamiento jurídico a la
vez que reconocen que este tipo de
acciones no son extrañas en esta gestión
gubernamental y debilitan la democracia
bukele ha acumulado un amplio respaldo
de la población tras supuestamente estar
ganando la guerra contra las pandillas
en medio de cuestionamientos sobre
abusos de poder y violaciones de
derechos humanos de mantener este
respaldo muy probablemente buque le
podría hacerse nuevamente con la silla
presidencial